good morning i'm dr christopher dunch
[Music]
today we're going to be operating on
rose keller patient presented with
severe back pain diagnosed as a
herniated disc
it is important we are in and out with
as little fanfare as possible
so mouths shut ears open let's begin
hey doctor i heard you came across some
of christopher dench's surgeries
sir there's a lot of bleeding focus on
your job
how is the patient perfect there's a
hemorrhage here you need to fix it
so there were no complications i don't
have complications
i can't make sense of this it's like he
knew what he was supposed to do
then he did the exact opposite i could
have told you the guy was a hat
what did he do dorothy burke walked in
all on her own and now she's brain dead
today will be minimally invasive and
turned him into a quadriplegic
work ted bundy was a good worker too
we all make mistakes but not you no man
dutch has two deaths texas has executed
people for less
all due respect dr kirby you don't
understand the law
you don't understand who we're after
dunch is never gonna stop
on his own we have to protect the public
and suspend his license
my patients mean everything to me and
the longer i'm here the longer they're
in pain
if you hurt these people you saw what he
did to them
i swear i will make sure this never
happens to anyone else
if you take my license in texas there's
an entire world out there
the system is broken i have a suggestion
it's a bit extreme
he's either the most incompetent surgeon
i've ever crossed
paths with or he's a sociopath
you